وهذا الفشل المدور ربما للقبه الحديديه في
المناطق الوسطى يعني يثير علامات سؤال حول
ربما اداء القبه الحديديه التي يعني اثبتت
في الجوله السابقه قبل اسبوع فشلا في
اعتراف طبعا سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي في
اعتراض الصواريخ ذلك ان القبه الحديديه
هنا في المنطقه الجنوبيه فعلا عليها ضغط
كثيف بواسطه الصواريخ التي تطلقها
المقاومه وربما تفشل في بعض الاحيان في
تنفيذ عمليات الاعتراض لكن ما الذي يجعل
القبه الحديديه تفشل في المناطق الوسطى
وهي مناطق لا تتعرض لكثافه نيران بمعنى ان
القبه الحديديه كانت يجب ان تعمل وفق رؤيه
الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي يقول بانها تحقق
نجاحات تبلغ 96% نجاحا في اعتراض هذا
الصاروخ وان لا يصيب مدينه الحوض وهذا
المبنى السكني لكن واضح بان كان هنالك فشل
كبير وهذا الفشل جاء بعد ربما دقائق
معدوده من الخطاب الذي القاه ب او الكلمه
التي القاها بنيامين نتنياهو قرب منصه
مقلاع داوود في احدى المناطق في وسط
اسرائيل والتي انتدح فيها هذه المنظومه
وقدرتها على اعتراض الصواريخ بعيده المدى
الاصابه المباشره في منطقه ريحوفت تدلل
على هذا الارباك والخلل ربما في منظومه
القبه الحديديه من خلال افلات هذا الصاروخ
اذا المشهد من حولنا هنا في المنطقه
الشماليه لقطاع غزه كان مشهدا ناريا
صاروخيا غير مسبوق هذا اليوم ومن الاقوى
والاشد والاعم منذ بدايه هذه